it's a good arm workout what could go
wrong oh i made only a little bit of a
mess
that was already so much easier
hello everybody welcome back to my
kitchen it's your girl merle and today
we're gonna be doing something very
exciting we're gonna be making our own
homemade almond milk before we proceed
i have a confession to make
i've made
oat milk and i've made cashew milk but
i've never i've never made almond milk
it's not that big of a deal but it's
kind of surprising right it seems like
it's pretty straightforward albeit seems
like it takes a little bit of time but
that's okay we got nothing but time
especially these days and then at the
end i'm gonna show you daily harvest
milk which is great because it's only
three ingredients it's another way for
you to make your own almond milk at home
but in a lot less time than what i'm
about to do so for our first step we're
just going to soak our almonds
a couple cups of water should work just
fine then we're going to pop these
babies in the fridge for up to 48 hours
or overnight
[Music]
now we wait
[Music]
i'm just kidding i already have some
soaking in the fridge
so we'll just drain these
we're gonna put our almonds in got some
water
and then for sweetness i'm using a
couple pitted medjool dates a little bit
of salt the diva of this recipe fresh
vanilla bean i'm gonna use the dull side
of my knife to scrape out the beautiful
insides
it's a little bit of a
pain in the neck all right
let's blend this bad boy
up let's strain this thing out i'm gonna
just do a little extra layer here this
is the second most time-consuming
element of this recipe all you need to
make this at home is
the ingredients and a little bit of
patience that's right just just enjoy
them enjoy the soft gentle sounds of
almond milk dripping into your jar
everyone lift from your meditation and
we are pretty much good to go
presenting merle's first ever homemade
almond milk
tastes like almond milk to me
look out kiddos maybe you'll see it on
the shelf someday
it would i it's not going on the shelves
because this takes way too much time
and i got other stuff to do so i'm gonna
show you an even easier way to make your
own almond milk at home and i'm gonna
grab some daily harvest milk from my
freezer this is great because it's only
three ingredients it's almond vanilla
bean and pink sea salt that's it no
added fillers or preservatives or
anything like that and the packaging for
this is completely recyclable so a
win-win-win all around so we're just
gonna take eight of these teeny little
frozen wedges add four cups of water
blend it together and that's it but you
could just make one cup of almond milk
or you can make a whole pitcher of
almond milk it's totally up to you
it's time to blend this up
that was already so much easier
it looks very creamy
smells fresh and it's cold unlike the
other one since it came out freezer it's
actually cold which is much more
refreshing
beautiful
and i think it's only right if i have
myself a little glass
fantastic very very smooth very very
creamy tastes great thanks for coming
along and uh i hope you learned
something
so i'm just gonna
get on out of here